la siguiente tabla muestra algunos
valores de la función g rafael piensa
que ya que g de 1 - g de 0 entre 10 es
igual a menos 5 debe existir un número
se en el intervalo cerrado 01 para el
cual g prima de c es igual a menos 5
cual condicionase verdadera la
afirmación de rafael aquí nos dan 4
opciones como siempre los invito a que
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolver
esto por su cuenta antes de ver las
opciones vamos a asegurarnos de entender
lo que nos piden rafael dice que se ve
uno que vale 3 - xerez 0 que vale 8
entre 10 que es esto esto de aquí es la
tasa de cambio promedio entre x igual a
0 y x igual a 1 otra forma de pensar en
esto es la pendiente de la recta que
conecta a los puntos 0 8 y 13 y esa tasa
de cambio es menos 5 aquí nos dicen que
debe existir un número c en el intervalo
cerrado que va de 0 a 1 es igual a esta
tasa de cambio promedio
eso se trata el teorema del valor medio
vamos a recordarlo
dibujamos unos ejes aquí está el punto
08 y aquí está el punto 13 la tasa de
cambio promedio es la pendiente de la
recta que conecta estos dos puntos así
sí cumplimos con las condiciones del
teorema del valor medio que son si
tenemos una función que luce así y es
diferenciable en el intervalo abierto
además de ser continua en el intervalo
cerrado entonces debe existir una c
diferenciable cuya pendiente a la recta
tangente en el punto c es igual a la
tasa de cambio promedio
este es el teorema del valor medio pero
para poder aplicar el teorema a esto
debe existir un número c en el intervalo
para el cual la g sea igual a la tasa de
cambio promedio debemos estar seguros de
que se cumplen las condiciones de este
teorema del valor medio que la función
es continua en el intervalo cerrado y
diferenciable en el intervalo abierto de
0 a 1
ahora veamos las opciones que es
continua en x0 y x1 esto por sí solo no
es suficiente también debe ser continua
en todos los puntos en este intervalo
esta opción no hace que la afirmación
sea verdadera g es continua en el
intervalo cerrado 0 1 esto está bien
pero no garantiza que la función sea
diferenciable en el intervalo abierto de
0 a 1 necesitamos que sea diferenciable
en el intervalo abierto además de que
sea continua en el intervalo cerrado
descartamos esta opción
que es diferenciable en el intervalo
abierto de menos 1 a 1 esto incluye el
intervalo abierto que nos interesa de 0
a 1 por lo que cumple con una de las
condiciones y continua en el intervalo
cerrado de menos 1 a 1 nuevamente esto
incluye el intervalo cerrado que nos
interesa de 0 a 1 esta opción luce bien
nos interesa que sea diferenciable en
este intervalo y si es diferenciable en
este seguro también es diferenciable en
este intervalo y que sea continua en ese
mismo intervalo esta opción es la
correcta la última opción nos dice que
es diferenciable en el intervalo abierto
y en x igual a cero esto se acerca
porque si algo es diferenciable entonces
también es continuo una forma de
interpretar esto es que es diferenciable
en el intervalo de 0 a 1 y que incluye
el 0 aunque esto se acerca si dijera que
esto es continuo en el intervalo cerrado
de 0 a 1 entonces sería una condición
suficiente ya que
si es diferenciable entonces también es
continuo pero no dice eso así que lo
descartamos no nos da la confianza
suficiente de que la función es continua
en el punto 1 hagamos otro ejemplo
diferente de lo que acabamos de resolver
qué es una función diferenciable
nuevamente nos dan algunos valores de
muestras de x x a max le preguntan si
hay una solución para g prima de x
igualados en el intervalo cerrado 36
aquí nos interesa el intervalo cerrado
de 3 a 6 lo primero que nos piden es
encontrar la tasa de cambio promedio de
3 a 6 esto es de 6 - g de 3 entre 6 - 3
g de 6 es igual a 1 y gene 3 es igual a
menos 5 el denominador es 31 menos -5 es
6 y 6 entre 3 es 2 este primer paso
tiene sentido nos preguntan es correcta
la solución de max sino cuál fue su
error veamos el paso 2 ahora max dice
que el teorema del valor medio garantiza
una solución para g prima de x igualados
en el intervalo cerrado de 3 a 6 debemos
tener cuidado aquí ya que quiere aplicar
el teorema del valor medio sin
asegurarse de que se cumplen las
condiciones de éste
así que yo digo que aunque nos dicen que
es una función diferenciable el error de
max está en que no aclara esto el paso 2
debería decir algo así debido a que es
diferenciable para todas las x podemos
decir que el teorema del valor medio
aplica en este intervalo y si queremos
ser realmente cuidadosos pueden decir
que debido a que esta función es
diferenciable para todas las x entonces
también es diferenciable en este
intervalo cerrado y si esto se cumple
entonces también es continua en este
intervalo cerrado por lo que podemos
aplicar sin problema el teorema del
valor medio y al final agregar que el
teorema del valor medio garantiza un
valor para esto hago énfasis en esto
porque si están resolviendo un examen
importante y quieren aplicar cualquier
teorema se les va a calificar el que
incluyen como parte de la respuesta
todas las condiciones necesarias para
aplicar dicho teorema y así asegurarse
de que lo pueden hacer y con esto
termina